what's going on guys this is rob and
episode 4 was as much an illuminating
episode as it was an episode that
basically told us nothing
at least as far as the bigger picture
goes right like it's obvious they're
kind of just building this up and
they're going to have a sort of reveal
that comes towards the end
when it comes to this though if i'm
honest and this is me just being crazy
and just throwing up just a crazy theory
out there
i don't know maybe they're going in the
direction of the seven heavenly cities
at this point it's anybody's guess
right because
one of the things to know for those of
you guys who are who were a little murky
about the episode from last week
the nature of the gen is that they just
come from what's called the nord
dimension in the marvel cinematic
universe but that dimension does not
exist in the comics there is no nor
dimension not like that anyway and my
initial thought when they when they
dropped like the nord dimension and they
were explaining the gin and that kind of
stuff my thought was okay so maybe the
gin are like a stand-in for like the
fall team and the faltenian dimension or
something like that but the difference
here is that in in marvel comics the
fall teen are just ridiculously powerful
magic wielders right that's what
dwarmamu is and his sister umar they're
faltens and so while the mcu may not
necessarily follow the direct origin of
dormammu from the comics i thought well
maybe they're adapting that to the
nature of miss marvel the problem with
that is that they're
nobody none of the gin that we've seen
are like magic wielders right i mean
they kind of are but not really right i
mean they don't really they're not on
like the level of doctor strange or
anything along those lines and
anybody who is an occupant of the
faulting dimension meaning they're
native to that dimension is more than
enough to be able to take on dr strange
right their ability to wield magic is
hitherto unrivaled by virtually any
being out there in marvel comics minus
like zom or the scarlet witch with the
life force or something like that so
they're ridiculously powerful and that
doesn't match any of the characters that
we've seen in the show that they
literally just seem like individuals or
beings who hail from a different
dimension however martial arts is a key
form of how they operate and how they
function
and so my thought here was okay maybe
they're really doing matt fraction and
ed brubaker's seven capital cities of
heaven like maybe that's the right of
the direction that they're going in now
one of the things and to kind of side
track for ms marvel here for a second
the seven capital cities of heaven was a
really cool concept and in fact it would
fit in very nicely with like talo from
shang qi and this it would fit in
actually it would fit in perfect so so
here's the explanation on that and and
you guys can kind of give me the skinny
on whether or not you would think this
or why not you think this would work
so iron fist is kind of the linchpin of
all that right or at least how it
started and the thing about this is that
for like decades in marvel comics when
they were writing comic books for
decades all we had was like danny ran
the iron fist in the sense that he was a
little kid whose dad was basically
betrayed and killed he was taken by the
people of kunlun to the city of kunlun
basically he stayed there he studied
there eventually learned how to use the
iron fist and came back to earth as a
superhero done but this mythology was
largely expanded on by matt fraction and
ed brubacher in their iron fist run
really more matt fracture than ed
brubaker but during the iron fist run
which was basically the seven capital
cities of heaven and the war or at least
the tournament that's fought by those
capital cities so the way this ended up
working or the way what we ended up
learning is that danny rand is only the
most recent iron fist that he is
actually just the current one in a long
line of people who were iron fists the
one before him was orson randall and
there were iron fists before him and
before him and him and him and just
going back just forever ago right just
for huge amounts of time and so what
happens is that every 88 years the
cities basically align and what it does
is it forms those seven capital cities
into one singular city and then a
tournament is fought and this tournament
was quite literally called the
tournament of the heavenly cities
so not the most creative name ever but
it was still a pretty cool concept and
so these seven heavenly cities again the
phrase cities is
i wouldn't say it's a misnomer it's more
just a general term they were cities but
it was more like realms right dimensions
that could only be accessed by those who
had the ability to access those
particular dimensions so unless you knew
how to access the city of kunlun you
couldn't just show up there right so
it's not like you know thor could just
be walking through the himalayas one day
and just decide to go to kunlun it
didn't really work that way you had to
wait until the the dimension of kunlun
aligned with the main marvel universe
and then once that quote-unquote gateway
opened then you could travel into it it
didn't happen all the time i think it
was something like once every 10 years
but my memory is a little fuzzy however
what you had were like kunlun you had
kunzi you had tiger island uh you had
the eighth city which was basically hell
you had like the under city uh there was
agabo i mean there were all kinds of
like little cities here right like like
territories it's got again a colloquial
name for like dimensions and so i don't
know if that's exactly what they're
doing with miss marvel the way that
walid depicted the dimension or at least
the nord dimension and the dimension of
uh of the gin is that what you have is
it seems like a plane
that's almost the size of earth now
whether or not that's done to scale i'm
not entirely sure but it looks like it
is right like he literally has that map
and he's like here's what our world
looks like in comparison to yours and it
basically looked like it was the exact
same size now the only the only way i
could see them getting around this is
those territories that were there that
he showed on the map only one of them is
the territory of the gem the other ones
belong to everybody else because there
are territories that were in like china
and places like that and so wouldn't it
be just a nice neat little thing if what
they did here is they basically said the
kingdom of talo and like the the realm
of the jinns like the nord dimension and
all that kind of stuff they're all just
the seven capital cities we haven't seen
all of them yet we've only seen a couple
of them but each one of these
individuals basically has a weapon that
makes them uh i guess makes them a the
avatar or the representative of that
particular realm effectively making them
immortal weapons because that's what
they were called in matt fraction's run
right like the tournament of the
heavenly cities and the seven capital
cities and so on and so forth the
individual representatives so like danny
rand the iron fist was referred to as an
immortal weapon we know from like the
miss marvel tv show that kamala khan is
just the most recent person to get her
hands on that bracelet now it doesn't
seem to be a generational thing it kind
of does but it kind of doesn't unless
there was something going on with their
mom that we don't know about then it may
very well be one of those situations
where it's just kind of arbitrary but at
the same time it does kind of fit the
iron fist run and the reason why is
because when you look at the character
of orson randall who was the iron fist
before danny rand that uh that orson
randle refused to fight in the
tournament of the the seven capital
cities or the heavenly cities and so
because of that like i mean it created
all kinds of issues but you literally
just transposed that onto ms marvel and
it could just be one of these things
where like the option was presented to
her mom and she turned it down her mom
was like no i don't want to have
anything to do with that i mean
obviously we do have those little
elements of her mom being kind of a
rebel deviating away from tradition
things like that like one of the
offhanded remarks that's made by i guess
a friend of the family or whatever her
name was when they first got to karachi
is that she referred to or she said that
kamal is not a traditional pakistani
name and that kamala khan's mom was
always a bit of a rebel so it made it's
entirely possible that she was just like
no i don't want to have any part of that
and then literally tried to keep her
daughter away from it she didn't want
her daughter to be a part of that either
but now that at least once kamala khan
comes along and reveals the reality to
her mom she'll be like yeah i know all
about it i didn't want you to be a part
of this that's why we moved that's why
we left because i didn't want you to be
a part of this whole thing this war
between the gen and and all these
individual factions of it right you know
i don't want you to have anything to do
with that so again like there's a lot of
cloak and dagger going on here right no
pun intended and and i'm not entirely
sure what the direction is they're going
in i mean truth to tell i would love it
if they were doing like the tournament
of the heavenly cities right like the
seven capital cities of heaven i don't
know if i would expect like shang chi to
show up in that whole thing but i still
think it's a cool concept i would say if
ever there were a time for them to
basically link the the bracelet of
kamala khan with the 10 rings it would
probably be in a post-credits scene at
the very end of the show and i don't
know if kamala khan would be like yanked
in by wong or something like that but
basically it's sending out a beacon like
some kind of post credit scene similar
to what we saw in in shanghai i don't
know if that'd be the case or not but
nonetheless again i'm just throwing out
theories i have no clue where they're
going here i have no clue i mean
obviously the main overarching theme
here is that if the bengal is taken that
that will lead to literally just the
entire second half of the nord dimension
just being conquered just being totally
taken over so at this point it's just
like a fight for survival and that
presumably these groups have been
fighting each other for some time i mean
we don't know how that barrier got there
it seems like it's always been there but
maybe it was erected as a kind of safety
mechanism i mean the funny thing about
that is it bears a striking resemblance
to like asgard those of you guys who
don't know like when asgard initially
came into existence you had the cold
side and the hot side there was a kind
of barrier there that basically kept
them separated and that's how asgard
evolved and grew and changed and so on
and so forth again you know that's
marvel comic stuff you know i don't know
how that applies to the mcu but at the
end of the day i will say i would love
to see them grab
the realm or the nord dimension and
basically roll it over into the
tournament of the heavenly cities right
the the heart of heaven is really what
it's called when all those little cities
merge into a singular city where the
tournament is held but i would love to
see them bring it in and make it one of
the seven capital cities because the
reality here is that the seven capital
cities of heaven most of those are of
asian descent right like that's that
seems to be the case and i guess descent
might not be the best word but are tied
into asian culture some of them are not
right zigabo is a city or is one of the
capital cities out in africa so they're
not all tied directly to
the asian continent some of them are
just sort of out in other places in the
world and that's why i say that's
entirely possible with that map right
that that map as it was shown at least
as waleed showed it to uh kamala khan
it's more of these are just one of the
dimensions right or at least this is
just one of the territories there's
other dimensions out there too and he
doesn't really give her the whole spiel
on the other ones in the same way that
you had that map and if you guys
remember in iron man 2 when you had nick
fury talking to tony stark and it was
like all the places that shield is
keeping an eye on one of which was
atlantis with name with a submariner
presumably i don't know who else would
be there but like that kind of a thing
right so again i'm not entirely sure i'm
just throwing out an idea here i mean
technically speaking i'm running on an
hour and a half of sleep so probably not
the best time for me to record this but
you guys get the point
but with that being said we're going to
bring this to an end let me know what
you guys think let me know if you would
want to see
the nord dimension that dimension itself
basically being turned into one one of
the seven capital cities of heaven and
and basically tying it directly into
like the iron fist mythos and all that
kind of stuff obviously the iron fist
does exist in netflix but literally if
you guys recall when kevin feige was
talking about the netflix netflix cast
being rolled over he was just like yeah
you know we're so excited to have
jessica jones luke cage and and and
daredevil
and no one else
specifically iron fist not him
that guy sucked so i wouldn't be
surprised if what we're looking at here
is the early onset of a wholesale reboot
of the iron fist mythos in the marvel
cinematic universe danny ran the whole
nine yards and that kamala khan and all
that is simply just one part of it
because i gotta say
that would be cool so with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end thank you all for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace